What smells so great?
Oh, that's just a clean person?
*laughing*
That's what a clean person smells like...
It's happening to us!
Guys, I'm here with Megan Batoon.
And I'm so excited!
I'm excited.
I have been obsessed with Megan's videos for probably the last year.
And finally I have enticed her over to my house
to participate in a challenge that only she and I could really, really relish in together.
It's an Autumn Candle Sniffing Challenge.
Rolls off the tongue.
We have collected an assortment of Bath & Body Works autumn scented candles.
And we will be blindfolded
and smelling them and trying to guess what the candle name is.
Do you feel confident in this?
Absolutely not.
Yeah, that's how I feel, too.
I just had like a moment of reflection on what this challenge actually is
and I-yeah, this is gonna be bad.
Jack Ferry-producer, director extraordinaire-is going to read us all the name of the candles
that have been purchased because we don't know which ones are actually, um, here with us today.
Here's the fun thing about candle names is that they have no
relevance to the smell.
Okay, so what are the possible names?
Jack: They are-
I'm nervous already!
I know-the anticipation
I feel like you're pausing as if this is the American Idol finale
where we're gonna find out who wins.
Jack: Alright, so we've got:
Perfect.
Oh...
Ohh!
What the f-
Do they do that?
..got it.
Jack: That's the same one. Thanksgiving Morning slash Pumpkin Pecan Waffles.
No, it's not!
Are you joking?
Why would you give it two na-
Wait, Thanks-
Jack: I don't, I don't work for Bath & Body Works you guys.
That person probably doesn't either.
Yes, of course.
Oh, okay.
I'm not a wood expert!
We're gonna have to smell it out, Megan.
We gotta smell it out.
I'm so ready.
Are you ready?
That pumped me up.
*laughing* Okay.
Let's do this.
And then we just shout it out until someone get it kinda close
Are your eyes closed right now, too?
Yes, I don't know why I do this!
Under blindfolds, I close my eyes.
Jack: And smell!
Thanksgiving Morning!
Pecan Waffle-
Mahogany Teakwood!
Jack: Yes!
*screaming*
Mother-that's the only one I could remember.
That smells great.
That actually is a great smell.
I like Teakwood.
Yeah.
That's not a table.
Where-
Palate cleanser...
Jack: Smell!
Thanksgiving Morning!
Soufflee pecan!
Waffles.
Pumpkin Cupcake!
Cranberry frosting.
Motherf***ers.
Vanilla cake batter-
Leaves!
Jack: Yes! Megan: Leaves?
Is this Leaves?
Jack: Yes!
F*** yes! This is not what leaves smell like at all!
If you put some leaves in like a Glade plug-in.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Jack: And smell!
Thanksgiving morning!
Jack: Yes.
*screaming*
F*** yes.
But I don't remember any other names.
You have been saying that one over until you got it.
This smells like..
like a Cinnabon.
Okay.
Jack: Ready?
Ready.
Jack: Smell!
Ohhhh. Woah.
Different.
Um, f***ing what's the-
*laughing*
F***ing. Is it f***ing?
What are the other ones?
*mumbling*
Um, the other wood one!
This-
Cedarwood!
Jack: No.
Like, huffing this into my face right now.
It's um
My nose couldn't be further in.
Cranberry.
Oh! That sounded like the right answer.
What is-
Can we get a hint?
Jack: Uh, I wouldn't say it's summer but I would say-
Pfft, that's the hint?
It's quite fall-AUTUMN.
Jack: Yes.
Nooooo! *screaming*
That's a good hint!
That was..
When you're blindfolded and you're just like huffing scents into your face,
it is quite an experience.
Ho mah god.
Woah this one's-
Ohhhhhh.
What the-
Jack: Smell!
Frosted cranberry!
Pumpkin Cupcake.
Jack: Yes.
F*** you.
F*** you. This does smell exactly like a Pumpkin Cupcake.
It really does. It's literally half and half.
This is really great.
I want to hate these so much!
Jack: And smell!
Cedar.
Plank.
Salmon.
What?
Um.
Um, pumpkin..
*laughing*
Is it anything with a pumpkin?
Cranberry frosting.
F***ing s**.
What's the other ones?
Vanilla Sprinkles.
Cupcakes.
Marshmallow Fire.
Jack: Yes!
*screaming*
I don't make s'mores. I just throw marshmallows deep into the fire.
The familiar smell.
My armpits are sweating.
Oooh. Profusely.
This is why I wore this shirt.
Jack: And 3, 2, 1. Smell.
What this is-
Cedar wood!
Jack: Yes.
No, this is Ivory Spring.
This is like a man's armpit.
This is a man's soap.
Kids, if you're concerned about college..
and like what your future holds..
all you need to know is
take a look at what you're looking at right now.
Reach for the sky.
Yup.
Is mine the sky?
Jack: Smell.
Ohh.
Frosted Cranberry!
Jack: Yes!
F***! I forgot that was not chosen yet.
And also this is delightful.
This is what addiction looks like.
Did you win? Did Megan win?
Megan!
Did I do it?
Congratulations..
Thank you.
I'm really proud of you..
If you guys want to see more impressive things,
please go over to Megan's channel here on YouTube because she does a variety of wonderful
uh, very cool entertaining things.
If you like to hear us engage in more dumb conversation,
then please go listen to the full podcast that we're about to record on iTunes or Soundcloud
Not Too Deep with Grace Helbig.
And Megan Batoon.
This is probably want The Weeknd did before he wrote that song "I Can't Feel My Face".
I'm pretty sure it was this candle smelling contest.
God, I wish.
And we'll see you when we see you.
I don't know.
And that's not it--that's not it at all.
Like, there's more injuries in a cheerleading gym
than like on the football field.
That's so crazy.
It's completely different. Like, competitive. It's hard.
Wow...
So how long did you do cheerleading for?
...ever.
Forever? *laughing*
It's--you're still cheerleading right now.
Doing it right now.